just enjoy the fact that you get to live
in a time period in American history
where the federal government seems to no
longer be denying the thing that people
have been saying forever but here's my
question then would be what's in it for
the federal government
that they would now not deny it well I
think that's one of the most important
questions regarding this situation is it
why why suddenly are they kind of slow
leaking this information like I don't I
don't know the answer to that like I
have no idea like well some things could
be I mean just off top my head is if
they want us to believe in some sort of
universal protector then that will come
along right like some things some
organization some like
insurance against aliens in a way not an
actual like you pay 40 bucks a month but
like right like as in creating some new
world or you know if there's that part
of that regime that like you know this
this one world order type of thing if
they yeah you know I'm just trying to
think of The Upside what does somebody
gain
um do we need a new enemy are they
realizing that like religion isn't
working enough on people anymore or the
fear of there's not enough fear imposed
on people at the moment you know I don't
know or it could just be that that's
blue beam you're talking about blue beam
that's the big conspiracy theory that's
like essentially like there's two
possibilities the one you just said
which I guess if you're gonna do like
Occam's razor that is the most likely
one right what is Occam's razor the
simplest solution is generally the
solution so uh in this case
it's more likely this is a human
operation than aliens based on our
understanding of physics and the
distance of habitable galaxies where
they have planets in the Goldilocks
region the amount of time it would take
to get here based on what we understand
about how fast you can go
probably if if you're gonna if you're
gonna bet bet it's not an alien right in
Vegas if you're betting you're probably
you should always bet that's not an
alien that's a human thing you're gonna
win most of the time right so uh that
that is one of the possibilities very
Sinister the idea being there's some
social control benefit related to
tricking the population of the planet
into thinking there's aliens that's
probably not the yakum's razor of it
then
I mean the other side of it is well we
live on a planet that's been being
visited by a variety of alien species
that more than likely genetically
engineered us a long time ago and like
shifted us from Proto hominids into what
we are now probably for a reason that
we're not gonna like like they like were
roombas or something I mean that's one
of the theories is they just wanted gold
so they genetically engineered us to
light gold so we Naturally Mine [__]
gold for them because we like shiny [__]
we like gold and that they use it as
some kind of fuel oh yeah have you seen
Basketball Wives dude no that the whole
show's about that oh gold right they
love gold that's crazy it's like yeah
what are we even doing here yeah right
it doesn't make sense like why do you
like this shiny stupid heavy [__]
metal why are you into that so much
there's so many other cooler Metals out
there but gold obsession is a real thing
so the theory is these anime knock you
programmed us to like gold because they
need it for their spaceships they didn't
give a [__] about us they're just like
uh let's form some gold here brilliant
from that perspective so that that to me
is a far more complex and and weird
explanation than just the
military-industrial complex has like
networked with other governments and
they're like
I think they're at the point they're so
[__] dumb they're gonna believe
there's aliens and like we can
manipulate them that's what it seems
like that's what it would seem like to
me because I don't know
unless it they're they're like we're
getting to the point where so many
people are being like there's so much
evidence the more you make me think this
is not real the more I'm just thinking
you are not honest right like at a
certain point the the the residual
effect of the of the magic trick isn't
um it doesn't cause the beautiful
deception anymore it causes you to hate
the magician exactly exactly so that's
the thing that's weird Bros like you
know
why why and look I would love to see it
would I like to meet an alien
I don't know dude
give me a break you know just from our
few podcasts together and conversations
we had I don't I think wouldn't you like
it of course you like to meet an alien
it'd be the coolest thing ever don't you
want to know what they smell like
no one ever talks about that what do
they smell like what is the what does a
gray alien's head smell like
um yeah
is it bitter is it a stinky smell is it
fishy
oh they're fishy dude
bro how much would the smell of aliens
depend on how much we give a [__] about
him anymore a lot
huge bro if they smell anything like a
Korean pet store dude I'm [__] gone
dude close encounters with Third Kind
spoiler if you haven't seen it I'm gonna
spoil it very end the guy who's been
building the mud mountains happily walks
into the spaceship the beautiful musical
spaceship imagine the [__] thing
closes and you catch that first waft of
deep like fish laying out in the beach
smell as you're like white speed heading
away from the planet and that's gonna be
what you smell forever as you look out
at the vastness of space black holes all
the beauty of space all you can think
about is there's just this stink rotting
eggs and [__] fish
hahaha
oh we would hate about aliens
immediately we would hate him like these
stinky [__] smell so bad and
they refuse to like take showers they're
like no we don't do that
no we'll evaporate you before we'll take
a [__] shower no we are the advanced
intelligence you're supposed to stink
they're like no this is one of the many
things we figured out yeah if you don't
stink you haven't evolved like we go we
used to not stink and then we learned we
learned this is our purpose here to emit
foul odors realizing there's more to you
than just being this reactive
substance described as like a human
reactive
is that what the aliens call us that's
probably what they thought it was at
first they're just like there's these
react there's a bunch of reactive
substance on that planet yeah I don't
know what it is sometimes it like gets
into
Vehicles we think it's Vehicles yeah
yeah once sometimes a doctor tells one
of them one of them tells another one
they have black guys in their head as a
child yeah I well you know I did like I
did read that maybe that is the reason
even though these days I guess you can't
say we're not getting visited but one of
the theories on why aliens are coming
here is because they don't consider us
intelligent life yeah so they just see
us as some just like what you're saying
some kind of like
vaguely sentient reactive meat and not
worth visiting I think that makes sense
I mean I've long thought the reason why
I think aliens used to come a lot
probably back in the day right they came
a lot that's why you saw a lot of
Egyptians drawing them yeah you know and
um and even the fact that they would
stay stable long enough for an Egyptian
to draw because an Egypt you know like
they had to get a candle they had to
light it they had to get the guy who
could draw like it was a little bit more
of them yeah sometimes chiseling yeah it
was more than just us grabbing a phone
right yeah
but I think
yeah they used to come by a lot and then
they realized it's kind of boring we've
become like one of the boring theme
parks in the Galaxy so if your parents
if you're alien parents take you to the
uh Earth yeah for your graduation I bet
the other aliens like what a [__]
loser to your parents to get a [__]
nobody's been there in Forever dude how
how poor are you guys it's like a Six
Flags knockoff yes like one of those
shitty like shitty theme parks where
they don't even try to clean up the puke
yeah they're just puke splattered
everywhere you'll probably get like
pickpocketed you look at the kids
controlling the roller coaster and
they're like clearly on PCP they're not
paying attention your people die you
know people die there but yeah yeah yeah
one of the guys running the rises in a
coma but they have to hide like the
governments like you have to hire more
comatose people yeah they're just like
yeah the guy's like just like has his
morphine button and his [__] start
the ride button confuse crazy Earth is
it's that old theme park where it's like
dude we're not driving all the way out
there there's nothing out there all the
information is these people are just
yeah trying to butt [__] and just
looking at you know and growing yard
drugs like we're not going over there
again I'm picturing the alien display
like the Star Trek display as that pops
up is what the analysis of planet Earth
is
that's amazing they're just like yeah
that's not worth our time yeah we're not
gonna burn best Bean crystals to [__]
go to that piece of [__] now it will at
some point though become hip with alien
youth to come back here and do something
because that's how everything is right
there will come a time and maybe it's
coming now because aliens seems to be
the you know gaining popularity I don't
know if it's gaining popularity or if
it's gaining
um like more sightings or whatever what
is this yeah this is actually pretty
topical NASA just held like a four-hour
press conference about UFOs for the
first time and they're basically
admitting that it's a daily Occurrence
at this point UFOs they're actually
there's one thing that's happened since
this weirdly boring NASA press
conference where they did say this did
you see the thing
there there's now a whistleblower who
has come forward and said that the
United States has alien spaceship
wreckage and a congressman I can't
remember his name gave a statement to
the Press saying they were debriefed
that in fact we have alien wreckage that
that they're about to have hearings on
it so all the UFO people are yeah that's
it that we're definitely not alone thing
people are really freaking out right now
because you know this is what all the
UFO people have been saying is coming
disclosure so yeah it's that guy a
whistleblower says he handed over
classified evidence proving that a
secret government program has been
recovering spaceships and aliens for
decades
uh we're definitely not alone David
grush
says uh he's a Former Intelligence and
Military official
um
uh
representative rep Republican Dean
Phillips a representative Dean Phillips
from Minnesota uh Democrat added my
first reaction is probably like
everybody watching this which is wow and
secondly I'll believe it when I see it I
mean that's fair you're not supposed to
immediately believe UFO oh no you but
but what's interesting about this is
that the denial that usually happens
when things like someone says it's not
really happening in the same way and
again there was a congressman who said
we were debrief like did you ever see
that creep so like they did hearings on
uaps a while ago and then after the
hearing they debriefed the feds the
Congress the Congress they debriefed
them
and they did an interview with one of
these representatives in the hallway
after he just got told whatever the [__]
they told him and he's he said you can
find on YouTube he said something along
the lines of lock your doors and windows
tonight folks that was his response like
whatever they told him
inspired him to say we should like lock
our doors like it's gonna keep an alien
out
lock your doors after classified hearing
on UFOs a Louisiana senator now we're
talking yeah man
this is the same state that couldn't
keep Brothers outside of my head when I
was a kid dude I'm telling you
you can watch can are you allowed to
show YouTube videos on you there's a
clip of him doing it it's hilarious him
right here doing it oh yeah that's it
flying objects that a couple of weeks
ago our skies were clear
and then all of a sudden we have spy
balloons and other identify unidentified
flying objects raining down on us like
confetti
that is not accurate
um
these objects have been flying over us
for years many years
we've known about those objects for many
years
we're not sure that we've known about
all of them but we've known about many
of them
except for the Chinese spa balloon we
don't know what they are
what's different about the last two
weeks is that we've started shooting
them down
but we can't find the remnants
except for the the the the Spy blind
and that's what I took away from the
hearing today
so I don't know if he paid attention
during the whole hearing then no
confetti raining down like confetti it's
a great descriptor
um yeah that's why I don't yeah I think
but maybe I could see if there's an
alien life form you shoot it you
whatever yeah and it it disappeared it's
part of the way it's constructed is not
to fall down to this that would be the
first thing I would make of something
that can't leave evidence right like
exactly but like based on the stuff
that's coming out right now and you know
I love UFOs in the same way I love like
stories about magic and miracles and I
but I don't go full bore into it because
ultimately like day-to-day reality
isn't impacted like you know mundane
reality right taking care of the kids
paying the mortgage so you can get too
distracted by that stuff and spin out
but this moment in the United States
history is really fascinating in the
sense that if we go back to Roswell it
was a weather balloon that's what they
say even though there's like many
accounts of people saying that they saw
aliens there was weird wreckage that uh
seemed to be able to like you could bend
it out of shape and it would go back
into the form it was just like weird
[__] right
this gets uh denied by the government it
was wreckage weird stories about it
whatever we get Area 51 you know what I
mean like it has its own airplane that
flies people in you get a variety of
like early phase government
whistleblowers like Lazar I think is his
name Alan Lazar
uh you get like uh that and then these
people get creamed in the media it's
like that's a lunatic you never worked
at area 51. this is [__] he's like a
con artist whatever but now what's
happening is instead of the denial that
generally follows the whistleblowers
admission of us like having some
connection to aliens it's not getting
denied as much anymore and in fact this
whistleblower program they just created
makes it so anyone who signed an NDA he
was a private contractor and has been
assigned to work on alien wreckage can
now come forward and say I worked on
this [__] and they get full immunity
because that apparently was the back
door like you so there was a these
programs you could hire like I don't
know name any like Raytheon I don't know
for sure they I don't know if they have
records I'm just throwing out like right
yeah Raytheon um higher rate Duracell
higher Duracell say look we've got this
ship it crashed can you guys hang on to
it try to reverse engineer it and so now
a private contractor has collected the
wreckage has the wreckage meaning if
you're asked under oath do we have
wreckage you could say no and because we
don't a private contractor has the
wreckage that was the loophole so now
they set up this whistleblower program
and all these people like that guy are
starting to come out people who just
like worked it Hyundai or I don't know
worked it like Dodge Neon Dodge Neon and
they were like hey what can you reverse
engineer this thing that seems to be
bending the time space continuum and
they're like no but they couldn't say
anything about it because they signed
these hardcore ndas so now they're all
leaking the data so we're getting this
weird slow leak from all these people
that's painting a picture and that's a
real program that they allow now how did
that program get created The
Whistleblower program so what was
happening was
um well the biggest problem is like
people
apparently people get around these
things and everyone listening you can
look all this up it's like all it's I
I've got the documents it's documents
it's real like it's not like I'm just
it's real you can find all this stuff
but
the biggest problem is you're a Navy
pilot yeah and you see something that is
not functioning according to your
understanding not Kosher seems odd it's
going so fast it's stopping it's just
stopping like it's a cursor on a
computer screen then it's going the
opposite direction it's jamming your
radar it doesn't seem to have Windows
right so you see that and your choices
are do I say I saw what is obviously a
UFO and if you do you could really like
[__] your career up yeah so you couldn't
talk about it the other problem is that
apparently people get too close to these
things they have there's a physiological
impact so let's imagine you got close to
one of these things and now you're sick
the VA won't pay for it right because
there are no UFOs what are you talking
about and so
inadvertently you end up creating a
situation where people won't say what
they're seeing up in the sky right which
isn't great if you're trying to defend
the sky we want to know what's out there
you want to know everything that's
flying through U.S airspace right so
yeah The Whistleblower program was I
think initially to kind of create a safe
wave a safe haven where people could say
okay this is what I saw I don't want to
endanger myself I don't want to endanger
not being able to get medical care and
things like that that's it yeah yeah and
and then
um and now it's sort of like now that
it's work working it's
you know all you need is like one person
to come forward it's like me too for
aliens just one person than the next
person to the next person to the next
person you know that's what's happening
all these people who've kept this [__]
like completely so I'm sure bottled up
imagine the people that have molested
people or something just because they
saw an alien and they didn't know how to
process it or went insane or like you
know like like uh so many things yeah
beat their spouse or just imagine a guy
he saw something in his whole life he
spent hiding things from like taking
anything and hiding you know like just
weird there's weird ways that people
react to things that are seem Beyond
them yeah you know it eats you alive and
then add to it that apparently these
people have been threatened with death
that whoever's running this [__] is not
[__] around they they don't want the
general populace they don't want the
world to know that this has happened
because apparently and again this is
just conjecture here
obviously from a military perspective if
you figure out how those things can fly
and you build a fleet of them you it's
like the new atom bomb like you are have
complete superiority in the sky and like
if we're you're living in the United
States right now you want us to be the
ones who want to be first you don't want
some other country who they apparently
all have this [__] to like win this race
but what about Mexico though you know
they don't have the [__] strongest
they're like no these [__]
don't that'd be incredible if all of a
sudden they have the most
some God is coming up with the [__]
and bro it's the lowest riding UFO ever
like the UFO is only like two inches off
the ground like dog this [__] is funky
it goes it it goes too high dawg we
don't this [__] goes too [__] high
that'd be so sick dude it would be right
if they proved aliens if there was some
proof for them like and obviously if
there was some further proof that really
set in everybody like everybody it was
like wow they're there they're out there
what would that do to religion do you
think that would strengthen it or do you
think that would weaken it
well I mean I you know I think it
depends on the religion and the lineage
of the religion I mean if you've been
living in a religion that is doing the
same thing for Humanity that we used to
do for planet Earth the Earth was the
center of the universe so if you've been
living in some mindset that humanity is
the you know the sum total of or like
the the final part of God's creation or
something then yeah it's gonna [__] with
your head because now you have to deal
with the fact that no there's the
universe is teeming with life on every
level from the subatomic to the like to
to to to
giant planets to God knows what to the
point where we might be some Atomic
portion of something we'll never
understand so yeah but I think you know
a lot of religions already have built in
the idea that we're talking about the
source of all reality a kind of super
intelligent progenitive
uh benevolent Creator force that just
Delights in making stuff and delights
and like sharing
its creation with the things it makes
that we get to co-create with it it
invites us to like sit down at the
potter's wheel with it and make stuff
while we're here so it's a really
wonderful artist whoever it is whatever
it is and it's the best kind of artist
it doesn't like where are the there's no
signatures there's no
copyright there's no IP it's claiming
for the sum total of all things it's
that incredible it's it's like Banksy
nobody knows who Banksy is it's like
that it's just like here have it all I'm
giving you all of it let's see what you
do with it yeah it's beautiful so I
think from that perspective aliens sure
why not and what if aliens they also had
a God too what if they rolled up with a
couple Gods we did we would figure it
out well yeah that was that's where it
would that's what that's what would be
so exciting it's like what who do they
believe in who are you worshiping who is
your god what is an alien god like and
what do they think of our idea of God or
their what if they're like all like
Richard [__] Dawkins and they're
pissed at us like there's no goddy dumb
[__] we made you we're your [__] god
look at his big black eyes emotionless
face
we made you you just hallucinated all
the other stuff because we built that
into you it's like believe in a God
because that makes you easy to control
we would beat them up then
we were oh dude I think we would I think
we would fight to have a God the first
alien human world star fight like when a
human finally just punches an alien it's
weird to think our kids might see that
man
it's weird to think that we might see
what
I don't think there's a lot of beef
between black I have some black friends
and they said there's a lot of beef
between like blacks and Aliens too what
yeah that's like we don't hear about
because we're not you know I guess in
that culture that much but yeah there's
a lot of like
black alien what yeah they don't get
along or they don't
yeah they don't get along that much I
mean how many black dudes you even know
were like yeah who have like alien
posters or anything like that you know I
mean I I honestly I don't know anyone
who has alien posters but like I do know
black people who are like super into
aliens I but maybe maybe I gotta meet
more black folks then you know maybe
yeah who knows it's like I I don't know
I mean I get I know there's a lot of
people who like are think they're demons
I mean that's one of the threads of
of like that's one of the explanations
for them is it's like no these are the
legions of Satan coming to the Earth to
pose as aliens and trickus into getting
on those [__] ships
don't get on the ships yeah don't get on
the ships because they're gonna fly you
right to Hell [__] don't get on
the ship I'm gonna want to go look at
least on there I bet well yeah of course
me too we will get on the ships but I'm
gonna say hey tell me before y'all leave
no dude you will get on the ship for
sure I guarantee you'll get on the ship
I guarantee it we'll probably be
podcasting on a spaceship at some point
I mean maybe that is what we're on here
yes maybe that's a part of it they get
you on the ship they make you forget
you're on a ship they trick you into
thinking you're in the human Dimension
we're just in some Cargo Bay right now
plugged into the Matrix baby
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one